i'd be so bad in an office would you i
did it for years and i got fired i got
fired all the time like kyle
i worked for this she does the taxes for
the
rockefellers
all i had to do was do take a long time
yeah i just had to do copying and she
brought me to the office and she goes
you do terrible work and i was just a
copy boy and i was like 24.
dude i remember actually i used to mail
forms my job was mailing forms right
form mailer right
and i did a bunch of mushrooms or lsd
one time and went in there right this is
insane bro and it was my girlfriend's
mom this was in high school
i got stripped down got completely naked
right okay
well that's not even half of it
so i walk out of the world
i walk out of the workplace the second
that two women see me naked walking
out of the workplace i'm fired
immediately right so
but i'm so [ __ ] up i didn't know got
into my car 84 ford escort with a
missing passenger seat somebody stole it
and
i get home anyway finished the drugs
wear off blah blah blah lose my job
but here's the crazy part a week later
one of our company one of our associate
companies in new mexico got all my
clothes in a box how crazy is that did
you mail them yeah
that is an insane story did you you knew
you were naked at your office
or you didn't know you were so high you
didn't know you were naked when i do
heavy drugs i get real native americans
so i go back to the roots you know yeah
i get back to like we don't need this
we don't need this common thread of you
know this brit this [ __ ] this british
guard we don't need so your story though
like you deserve to be fired and like
that's cool and you were like i was
trying really hard to make copies and i
got fired you you were having a good
time
i mean
i don't know what i was doing man but we
were both
somehow inadvertently though we didn't
know it looking for something different
yeah there was a part of us that was
like i'm gonna [ __ ] this up i think so i
think i was like no i'm never going to
do i can't do this so this compadre ends
up at the right bowl of walkable yeah
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one